who would have thought a few centuries
ago that in the 21st century practically
everyone on earth would have an
opportunity of actually observing mars
being explored
and today thanks to the perseverance
mars rover
we'll be bringing you the very latest
updates
let's get started
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
to date perseverance has stayed 36
souls on the red planet
it has beamed back a great number of
high quality pictures for us to check
out
here are some of the latest
these two images were taken by the rover
on sol 32
using its on-board left navigation
camera
which is located high on the mast
this image was taken on the same day but
with its on-board right navigation
camera
[Music]
these images were taken by the rover
shortly before this video was posted
[Music]
in addition to those one of the most
exciting things
captured by the rover is a travelling
sound whirlwind
which is popularly known as the dust
devil
in the video posted on space.com the
dust devil is seen to be traveling from
the right to the left
no information about the whale wind's
size and rate has at this point been
made public by nasa
still as giant dust whirlwinds are a
common sight on mars
there'll be plenty of opportunities for
the rover to study them in more detail
since the size of these dust devils is
dozens of times that of whirlwinds on
our earth
they might pose a serious threat to the
machinery
so specialists at nasa will have to
watch out for them and make sure that a
safe distance is maintained between them
and the rover at all times
another important kind of information
received on earth from perseverance
is sounds recorded on the surface of
mars
in the past few weeks the rover has
captured several recordings
for example in early march nasa posted
the sound of the rover zapping rocks
with its laser
while investigating them and here is the
sound
in this short recording we can hear the
laser impacts
the shots were taken from a distance of
about three meters
some impacts are louder than others
which will help researchers gain deeper
understanding of the target's physical
structure
for example about varying hardness of
different rocks
in other more recent recordings we can
hear the mars rover rolling along on the
martian surface
in the first audio file we can hear raw
sound
recorded by perseverance as it was
moving along the jezreel crater
the noise was generated by the
interaction of the rover's wheels and
suspension with the surface
as for the high-pitched scratching noise
it may either be electromagnetic
interference from one of the rover's
electronics boxes
or else interactions between the rover's
mobility system
and the planet's surface the second
recording is a short compilation of
segments
taken from the original audio file which
was unprocessed and unfiltered
[Music]
and now for the biggest news about the
mission
the recent announcement with details
about the first test flight of the
ingenuity helicopter on mars
earlier the debris shield was dropped it
was protecting the helicopter when
perseverance was landing in the jezreel
crater
then nasa's controllers searched for the
best takeoff site for the rotorcraft
a month since the rover's landing they
found a suitable
location there were two criteria that
predefined the choice
the flatness of the surface and no big
rocks
it didn't take long to find the place
the planned takeoff site for the
helicopter is just a hundred meters away
from the rover's landing site
nasa also announced that the test flight
is planned to take place not sooner than
on april the 8th
the event may probably be postponed for
several days
mission controllers also hope to take a
few pictures with the cameras
mounted on the ingenuity helicopter when
going five meters up and higher
the rotorcraft will be able to observe a
rather vast stretch of martian terrain
as for the test flights they are going
to continue for about 30
earth days perseverance has been on the
red planet for over a month now
in this period it has captured images of
the martian surface
and sound recordings thanks to geologic
experiments it has carried out
scientists found that some martian rocks
are similar to volcanic formations on
earth
in terms of their chemical composition
as for the main experiments of the
mission
we still have a few months ahead of us
before they start
after the rover completes all the
planned tests it will move on to the key
part of its mission
which is probably the most exciting for
all of us back on earth
as search for extraterrestrial life to
that end
perseverance will have to drill the
bottom of the jezreel crater
and extract some rock samples these
rocks may reveal traces of life in the
distant past
as they probably witnessed the times
when there were seas and oceans on mars
scientists at nasa will receive the
samples with whatever evidence they are
to reveal
not sooner than in 2031.
while we are looking forward to results
of the investigations
perseverance will perhaps show us many
more exciting finds to marvel at
i in my turn will do my best to be in
the loop at all times
and keep you posted on the cosmo channel
whenever anything comes up
how did you enjoy the video are you
looking forward to the test flights
feel free to hit the like button and
share your opinion about the mission in
the comments below
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you